[Musique]
attention aux patrons notre nuage arrive
de plus en plus près des étoiles
lutteront nounours ce ne sont pas des
étoiles ce sont les lumières de la ville
regarde mais oui tu peux
nous sommes arrivés chez nicolas et
pimprenelle je descends leur apprendre à
regarder au loin avec des jumelles
europe pape appelle popotin
bonsoir nicolas brault soir imprenable
[Musique]
bonjour doucement
oui mais faites attention elles sont
fragiles j'y tiens bon
[Musique]
ce
n'est pas fait pour regarder de cyprès
les jumelles il faut s'en servir pour
voir au loin
pour voir les étoiles les bretagne les
courses de chevaux
oui tu vas voir une course de chevaux
[Musique]
allez
ne veut pas trash pâle mois
jaloux
[Musique]
je
vous avais pas pousser les cheveux il
faut leur donner les bases de la foi toi
vous commencez à gérer je ne veux pas
jouer australe
je ne suis pas ta dans oi
une bande de gars tu es agro mignon
petit
[Musique]
nom je suis très fâché rendez moi ma
jumelle je voudrais
au
garnement or je ne viendrai plus vous
voir vous êtes trop
méchant
a
[Musique]
lieu
alors nounours était belge humaine on
sait pas trop comment ils colorent et
pimprenelle sont d'horribles petit
diable c'est fini je n'irai plus jamais
les voir ils m'ont humilié
vous vous rendez compte ils m'ont traité
comme un an
le vilain olemps console toi ce sont des
enfants ils sont méchants aujourd'hui
mais demain ils seront très gentil vous
croyez j'en suis certain jo les hommes
seul mot est aussi le thème le ch leurs
petits en route patron bonne et des
enfants faute de boer
bonsoir
beau
sauf une tête north je ne suis pas
content patron nicolas et pimprenelle
ont été si méchant avec moi hier soir
quand je ne descends pas les voir rien
qu'une petite minute north pour les
mettre au lit nous on est non je le
renvoie à ma place ce petit chat qui
l'aura mettra de ma part une très grande
lettre mais moi je ne descends pas
bonsoir petit chat
essaye de les rendre charge et au
panier cette annonce qu'il envoie est
lourd le pr
michel
[Musique]
tient rigueur pimprenelle il apporte une
lettre ça j'attends lilas mais je sais
pas les icônes à ce mot là c'est sûr
vous êtes une nourrice on pourrait lui
téléphoner oui ils étaient les fans
étoiles
000 ha long et les nuits à la parole
c'est ma crème et nicolas c'est toi qui
nous a écrit oui
merci pour le petit chat assez bas lire
nous
et bien les enfants je vous écris pour
vous dire que si vous l'êtes pas savent
je ne viendrai plus vous voir et que je
me mettrais très en colère
oh qu'est ce que c'est que ce bruit dans
le téléphone
a nantes au dodo allô maman
c'est le petit chat il t'offre la db7
chat ma nous on va toujours trop sage
pour te faire plaisir
evreux s'est promis de nous et on va
tout de suite en ligne est en quête d'un
des gros pc et merci pour le petit chat
tata
oui je suis très content je viendrai
demain au nonu et n'est pas multi choix
d'armes autres et sa
petite soeur bien
[Musique]
et voilà un nounours heureux aux patrons
ceux qui sont mignons quand ils ne font
pas de caprices et bien ne vous fatiguez
pas bonne nuit les enfants
embrasser bien fort aux parents soyez
toujours bien sage avec nounours est
fait pour
[Musique]
bonsoir les hauts-fonds grand soir nous
ne faisons que passer car je crois que
nounours ne descend pas chez ses amis ce
soir monsieur patron messieurs je veux
je croyais que tu étais fâché avec je le
suis plus jr je leur ai envoyé un petit
champ à ma place mais ce soir c'est moi
ils m'attendent bon le cheval le hop hop
hop hop hop de tels propos
[Musique]
alors comment se porte-t-il ce mineur
créé bien des morts cinq heures il a plu
presque tous en lait petits gourmands tu
viens dire bonjour a vu l'ours au
prorata matin où vas tu
[Musique]
il me chatouille voyant lance le faire
non ce sur batteur du nom vilain tu ne
manques pas tous peur elle est trop
mignonne sur monet maintenant non noël
halloween c'est l'heure pour les petits
chats de fer baudot
alain cotta dominer tu vas faire un gros
dodo de chats ne faisons pas de bruit il
va sans dire
sur les châtaignes chanson c'est une
très bonne idée
moi c'est la fin de la journée
c'est le moment de se couchait nous
faisons comme nos amis il est sans doute
son lit
nous y allons aussi
sur son nuage
j'en suis certain le marchand de sable
vienne
il nous dira
mais vos yeux et dormi tous les deux
nous sommes bien dans notre lit none of
nous souhaiter bonne nuit
sa grosse voix me fait plaisir quand je
vais dormir
quand je vais m'endormir
safra nous fait plaisir
[Musique]
à présent que ce chaton dans vous allez
faire comme lui a nui nenê ce bonne nuit
les petits
la jette à l'honneur
fait pour
oui
[Musique]
alors ne nous rien à dire patron ils
sont parfaits même le petit chat s'est
endormi sagement j'espère que tous les
petits enfants vont faire comme eux mon
petit doigt me dit que quelques enfants
pas beaucoup ne vole pas le se couche à
ton petit doigt se trompent 90 mais oui
ils se trompent le garnement banni des
enfants fêtes de bourg eux
[Musique]
par les enfants beaux dauphins
à qui souhaite une bonne fête ne nous
reçoit nicolas patron à tous le petit
nicolas c'est demain la saint nicolas
mais c'est cette nuit qu'il vient bonnes
feuilles le nicolas dont le seul euro
pop pop pop pop pop
[Musique]
chic
tiendront deux chatons qui s'est faite
nicolau
ouais mais sous cette nuit que
saint-nicolas bien et nous avons mis nos
souliers dans la cheminée et notre petit
panier aussi j'y ajoute le cadeau de
noblesse
qu'est ce que c'est non ne vois pas je
le ferai moi-même demain cela fait un
mois n'ont ni mon petit nicolas il faut
être sage les enfants sinon saint
nicolas ne viendra pas ce feuillet vous
savez qui c'est saint nicolas mais bien
sannikov black rot des écoliers apportez
moi t'es pas comme un petit badge je
saurai toujours sage comme à petit
mouton que diraient mes prières pour
voir du beau monde est venu saint
nicolas je ne veux des à nicolas rené
vincent colonna
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sa nuit quatre ont déjà rallié
apportez-moi des panneaux montrent
équipe a dit je saurai toujours sage au
mas petit mouton qui
[Musique]
venait venu saint nicolas venez venez à
nicolas alors
bonne fête ni à la merci d'un webinaire
une heure
le petit chat quelqu'un amaury ne le
voit l'enjeu le tuant un long petit coca
au dos d'un rythme inégalé venu
j'attends de bourrel à tous
maninona ce bonne nuit les petits
endormez vous vite
là j'éteins la lumière
tu crois qu'il va venir ça nicolas bien
sûr c'est mon c'est à moi connu prenait
lé gardien petit frère
[Musique]
volley ball du show nicolas raulot
partons vite nounours avec un peu de
chance nous le rencontrerons peut-être
dans le ciel au ch sont nicolas ça fait
si longtemps que je ne les ai pas vus
bonne nuit les enfants faute de pauvres
lol
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au
alors nous nous voici enfin de retour
mes chers petits amis ce coup je me suis
ennuyeux sans vous patron je descend
vite jouée chez nicolas hulot propose
windows mais n'oublie pas qu'il doive se
coucher de bonne heure
[Musique]
allons sur la peur je suis bien content
de voir les pots
cassés la vie
n'y
a personne
[Musique]
un
oiseau à ibou même ses
jumeaux chargé d'un bonsoir les enfants
personne n'osera gare regarde on a une
visite du lieu tant mosher comment
vaincu mais tu n'es pas venu seul
que la voulez pas je vais voir
[Musique]
grâce à hybris
rejouer chants catho des pins tu as bien
fait de venir je tue le selon sud cette
formidable salut salut d'un méchant
pollue beau parce que tu es chargé
d'âmes dont va t'aider oui tiens tiens
moi ça le nous
pesons me réussit bien sûr cornichons
bon mais j'ai encore des affaires sur le
panu on va les chercher les chercher on
y faire attention tu fragile
très bien là
ce que le pico ce soit contre une minute
je reviens
dada
ça y est tu as papaya moment que c'est
d'accord je peux rester
[Musique]
tu reviendras insurgés
du donjon j'aimerais bien savoir
pourquoi la porte on a
pour juliette à west à genève
attention à mais pas tous
tu peux lâcher il tient tout seul c'est
un beau chaque année oui mais c'est
aussi là vaut pour juliette eh bien mon
petit corps du show tu as fait une
longue route pour venir ici tu es
sûrement fatigué
non vous jouerez demain toute la journée
à lui ou les
qui viendrait jouer avec nous
bonne nuit
en une annonce vannes n'est qu'un
méchant ou tortue cochon t'inquiète pas
nous nous je prépare mon quoi près de la
forêt avec juliette
salut
bonne nuit nous nous
fais de beaux rêves
[Musique]
oh
je l'état ne va pas dehors cette nuit
c'est un pays que tu me connais pas tu
pourrais te perdre
dans bien juliette 1
[Musique]
allons-nous nours dépêche-toi voilà à
trop connue des enfants à demain fêtes
de bourg
[Musique]
nounours nous sommes arrivés oui
nounours nous sommes au dessus de chez
tes amis tu ne descend pas les voir on
shore pas trop jurés volontiers le
rendre visite si cornichons et est un
peu plus ordonnée j'ai trop peur de
trouver un désordre terrible aussi je
préfère lire cet excellent roman police
ou julio toi tu m'as fait peur j'ai
l'impression que juliette a est venu le
chercher ce possible que je le dirai pas
allons-nous nours ne fait pas la
mauvaise tête mais une juliette à mes
notes de toute ligne elle me les a
prises et répartit pas tort que je
t'attrape les vos ados propos propos
à la gêne est
cocu
bonsoir pas preneur cette ville elle
juliette a m'a pris mais lunettes rouler
mois à l'eau
[Musique]
non alors cornichons viendront des
selles vilaine birds mais où est-il
encore celui là je suis dans la cuisine
où nous
passerons beau c'est ton petit déjeuner
que tu prépares corner chaud non s'est
posée y est un an elle ne le mérite pas
celle là elle m'a pris mais lui ne tu
t'en fais pas c'est pour jouer mais je
veux qu'elle me les rentes mois elle te
les rendra c'était gentil
tiens tout
ça a l'air vraiment très bon
ah oui alors c'est bon
juliette a s'est envolée
jules guesde vient agiter
si je comprends bien venu trop tôt value
je vous avertis solennellement si je ne
retrouve pas tout de suite
je vais me fâcher au merlan c'est pas
tant de bruit tu vas lui faire peur elle
s'est cachée il fouette un lumière et
elle va revenir très bien allez tous
vous coucher j'aiderai mais si thomas
elle ne me rends pas mes lunettes
je serai très fâché et je ne vous
parlerai plus tu les auras tes lunettes
on fait le trophée et on te donnera
demain soir c'est promis bonne nuit ils
nous
vont lui
tout remué
8,1 domo bonne nuit de noces à demain
[Musique]
moi
alors nounours et et lunettes je n'ai
qu'à me les rendra demain pas trop c'est
une qu'aucune pourvu qu'elle ne me le
crash à ne devait pas de souci elle est
très soigneuse
allons en août en route bonne nuit
demande
pour
[Musique]
soir les enfants pauvres
ou le seul mais tu es fort pressés nous
n'aurons oui j'espère que cette coquine
de julio tas a rendu mes lunettes à
nicolas et a pas preneur or selon avec
son hip hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
même si
le doubs en avec koné pour toi je trop
gentil ou semblait même prêt c'est
encore une image qu'elle était beaucoup
plus beau tu là je ratais lunettes et
craque
encore dijon où es tu
tout cela drôle
bien n'attends rien
tu reviens
merci maman vient d'une seule
raison à guy bourras quand les gens tu
vas être très propre
bravo à gilles cornut joe vereecke or
les gens
savent à toi bien chargé qui l'attrapent
soir au toit avec la brosse lui aux
apparitions
ça va salut nous
tu viens d'où de prendre une douche lui
mais avec un imperméable c'est plus
brutaux
enfin cornichons on remporte sa douche
avec train a permis à six mois toujours
pas prenez les nicolas rouly ne trouve
pas ça drôle du tout
prendre sa douche avec un imper noir
il aima la commission oui alors à quoi
bon tant que tel une note tu vois on les
a mis dans sa belle est cuit ou ce jeudi
murs le zoo
la nuit comme les chants venus je vais
dormir de ma forêt dont un forain à
wilfred marbre avec juliette à
moi pas mieux non année là je teins la
lumière
salue les gens
[Musique]
de nuit les petits
il a de curieuses
et cornichons c'est très agréable de
prendre une douche je suis bien de votre
avis pas trop petit par moments mais
j'ai récupéré mes lunettes avec apple
depuis le cher petit bonne nuit les
enfants ne faites pas comme cornichons
car vous feriez de la peine à votre
maman
allez vite vous coucher c'est fait pour
bonsoir les enfants
écoutez pas tout mais qu'y a t'il moors
vous l'entendez pas pleurer mais non je
suis certains clients un bébé qui pleure
pauvre petit peu je descends vars je le
trouve europe hop hop hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
[Rires]
et
puisque c'est comme ça mohamed mazet
café voilà
je pense tu jeûnes abus qui pleuvent les
caprices qui fait des caprices oui alors
match les mises au point pauvre petite
tape russe
allons où es tu cap russes
tu vas recevoir une fessée à
ses filles avec leur poupée que fais-tu
comme jo je prépare mon lit je me couche
tôt je suis raisonnable mois n'est ce
pas juliette à
la
bonne nuit tout le monde
home est la voie la plus simple
ça mais recule à gronder alors là du
chagrin
si nicolas n'a pas de saignement de nez
caprices et ma fille y avoir un grand
rôle le jour du fis il faut être
raisonnable comme cornichons c'est le
moment d'aller au lit
à vous tron
[Musique]
je suis la marchande
stable la journée est finie il faut être
raisonnable
c'est le moment d'aller au lit
[Musique]
tous les jours sur mon nuage
nous nous revient avec moi et nous
partons en voyage
dans le ciel par dessus les toits
[Musique]
je n'ai pas d'autre bagages
qu'un niveau
enchanté et du haut de mon nuage
je serai memon stable doré
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants du monde
à demain bonne nuit moi je continue ma
ronde
de nuit à tous les menus
au 9e nuit à tous les petits
bonsoir les enfants je sais que vous
êtes tous très sage ce soir car vous
attendez le père noël mot sur ton leur
bord un long gros farceur tu sais bien
que le père noël devient que chez les
petits enfants mais je suis tout petit
patron et je suis très
[Musique]
nigauds prends ton échelle et descend
voir tes amis bureau hop hop hop hop hop
hop ou bo bo je
vais mettre la cheminée mais c'est plein
émoi mais pas un gars doux
mais je trouve plus qu'à sept lots et
moi ne trouve pas du tout mes souliers
bonsoir oh je vois que vous préparez vos
chaussures pour le père noël
je n'aimais pas
c'est terrible j'ai plus qu'un chevalier
blanc et moi je peux de te saoule y
allons ducale poids comme show c'est une
taupe rames de papier du tout la journée
tous les retrouverait des chaussures
qu'ils avaient rangé
c'est plus cher
[Musique]
leur peau pas preneur tiens regarde ces
petits vernis noir sont ravissants mais
cela dont la cheminée
[Musique]
cinq ans que je suis là et je les
mettrai pas la cheminée est ce qu'un
sens propre mais m
[Musique]
non non je trouve
regard nicolaï mes chaussures elles
brillent encore plus que
le petit aura moins de jouer
nous sont pas là non plus alors il se
souvient encore des gens je les trouve
pas lourd dit tu vois que le père noël
va quand même venu
je ne suis pas j'ai une idée je vais
mettre mes chaussettes à la place mais
je vais les laver avant ces tunnels av
elles ne seront pas sèche hors du temps
la région j'ai aimé comme ça
nico leur premier salaire je manie
chaussettes ont acheminé moi je mets
même des nombreux imams et rami
synthétique je suis sûr que le père noël
va vous apporter d'être à de beaux
cadeaux du temps je me sauve et vous
souhaite une belle soirée tonneaux à
demain annonce enfin monument chéri
donne l amith très bien nos dollars
levant haut
[Musique]
où
en route patron ce soir se peut et je
souhaite à tous nos petits amis de
passer un joyeux noël et avec tous nos
grands amis aussi joyeux noël
a dog
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est toujours du noël
bonjour thierry de toute une année et
moi je dis avec patronat et la vie va
mal et
genton chantons noël
en choeur tous les deux nikon up du feu
louis chantant la chanson le plus par
genton chantons noël
qu'est la journée
la cheminée
et d'en construire
de beaux cadeaux
balgau jours donnant
elle ne vient pas souvent y en a qu'un
parent s'il y en avait tu dors
ribambelle
ce serait trop pour le perdant
quant à l'hiver
non
nadine touma
picado dans toute l'année c'est la plus
belle
genton chantons noël
et tous les types dans tous les pays
comme nicolas et pas 3 2
elles disent
vivre non
mais free vient didier et des surprises
[Musique]
sinon
bien trop lentement au gré des gens
enfants cette même latin
l'eau
[Musique]
chez new look
sans faire de poèmes pour te souhaiter
noël
on veut te dire qu'on t'aime et tu te
donner beaucoup
beaucoup de miel
joyeux
se met en veille un
merci
je savais bien que le père noël ne vous
dirai pas non
coup de gueule
miel de lavande
dormard un miel de tilleul
deux sapins que ce gentil
[Musique]
vous ont-ils pas chez
nous ça que j'ai pour te faire plier un
peu et nous nous couchons bien vite tous
les soirs bonne nuit mes enfants me nous
fait pour un
mineur marc deschamps bonne nuit les
petits
[Musique]
le père noël à pons siamois patron qui
est content de nous heureux patron vous
re all your doral joyeux noël à tous au
lieu dit
[Musique]
vous